LYLA FUJIWARA: At
I/O go this year,
we introduced the Android App
Bundle and Dynamic Delivery.
And if you don't know what those
are, check out the video below.
By simply using this
new bundle format,
you could see a substantial
size reduction in APK size
for your users.
But additionally, the App
Bundle enables modular apps
to download code on demand via
a feature called Dynamic Feature
Modules that's currently
released in beta.
So let's say that I have a chat
app that supports both video
and text chatting.
If some of my audience
never uses video chatting,
I can take out all of
the code and resources
for video chatting and put
them in a separate module.
Then in Android
Studio in Gradle,
I would configure this as
a Dynamic Feature Module.
Google Play will take your
App Bundle with this module
and create an
additional split APK
for the module known as
a Dynamic Feature APK.
Using the new Google
Play Core Client Library,
you can specify
when your app should
request the feature from Play.
Then Dynamic Delivery will
send the future APK on-demand
to devices running
Android L or higher.
And for older devices,
you can decide
whether to install the APK with
or without the dynamic feature
included.
The Google Play Core Library
enables a few delivery options
for dynamic features.
For example, here's the code
for requesting a dynamic feature
online, typically in
response to user request.
The Play Core Library
also provides listeners
for checking on and being
notified when a dynamic feature
is downloaded.
Google Play Instant
and Dynamic Delivery
are built of the same
concepts of modularization
and on-demand code loading.
So coming soon, you'll be able
to instant enable your App
Bundle, meaning that
your users can experience
your app or your
dynamic features
by simply tapping on a
link and without having
to install the app first.
With the introduction of the
Android App Bundle and Dynamic
Delivery, we're allowing for
automatically smaller apps.
And with dynamic features, we're
giving you the optional ability
to add dynamic code
loading to your apps.
To get started, head over
to g.co/androidappbundle.
And happy coding.